Fast and Furious 9 is no longer fast approaching
theaters and there's a chance fans will be
furious about it.
"You think this is a joke?
Huh?"
As confirmed by Variety, Universal Pictures
has delayed the ninth Fast film by almost
a year amid concerns over the worldwide coronavirus
outbreak.
It's the kind of thing that can make you want
to lean back, crack open a cold one, and wait
for it all to blow over.
“You can have any brew you want -- as long
as it’s Corona.”
The studio's decision arose after consideration
about the consequences COVID-19 a new strain
of the coronavirus family of viruses that
originated in Wuhan, China at the end of 2019
has already had on the global economy and
what the continual spread of the disease will
do to the film industry at large.
"One thing I can guarantee you, Dom — no
one's ready for this."
COVID-19 is, as of the making of this video,
most prominent in China, South Korea, and
Italy countries that have taken serious precautions
to keep their citizens safe.
Such preventative measures include cancelling
public gatherings, issuing quarantine orders,
and, of course, shutting down movie theaters.
Many outlets are reporting that the United
States may follow the example of these overseas
territories with regard to theater closures.
Noted Bloodsport fan President Trump even
evoked the action franchise, perhaps inadvertently,
while hosting the Irish Prime Minister on
March 12th ...
“When you think of what happened to Europe,
because it was very fast and very furious
Fast and Furious 9 was scheduled to open in
theaters on May 22, 2020.
Now, it will arrive on cinema screens on April
2, 2021.
International release dates are apparently
being ironed out, but the intention is to
launch the ninth Fast film worldwide in April
of next year.
The cast and crew of F9 released a statement
on Twitter addressing the delay which read,
in part,
"We feel all the love and the anticipation
you have for the next chapter in our saga.
That's why it's especially tough to let you
know that we have to move the release date
of the film.
It's become clear that it won't be possible
for all of our fans around the world to see
the film this May.
While we know there is disappointment in having
to wait a little while longer, this move is
made with the safety of everyone as our foremost
consideration.
Moving will allow our global family to experience
our new chapter together.
We'll see you next spring."
Though it's completely understandable why
Universal Pictures has delayed F9, what feels
particularly disappointing about this development
is that Vin Diesel, who leads the franchise
as the racing aficionado Dom Toretto, recently
assured fans that the film's release date
wouldn't be changed.
Diesel promised that F9 was sticking to its
planned May 22 release date.
In an interview published March 7th, Diesel
said,
"[I] won't fault anyone in the world for saying,
'You guys are stupid for releasing this movie
right now,' [but] we need movies now more
than ever.
We're already in a very interesting time where
cinema and the cinematic experience is so
threatened.
So, yes, put it on record we're going to show
up."
What's a double bummer about this situation
is that this isn't the first time F9 has suffered
a lengthy delay.
the film was slated to hit theaters on April
19, 2019.
However, when Universal prioritized the Fast
and Furious spin-off film Hobbs & Shaw starring
Dwayne Johnson and Jason Statham over the
main franchise entry, F9 was pushed to April
10, 2020 before later settling into its May
22, 2020 slot.
What's interesting about F9 being pushed back
almost an entire year from not its first or
second but third established release date
is that its new one is the exact date Universal
previously intended to release Fast and Furious
10, the installment meant to mark the end
of the core film franchise.
With F9 now occupying that slot, what does
it mean for Fast 10?
“If we do this, we risk everything.”
The simple and sad answer is that the film
will undoubtedly be delayed as well, and probably
substantially at that.
Production on the film has, of course, not
started yet, and it isn't as if it can begin
in the middle of a global health crisis.The
best case scenario is that filming on that
flick will probably begin sometime next year
which means that, accounting for the time
it takes to complete a movie in post-production,
the 10th Fast and Furious film will most likely
receive a spring 2022 release date.
F9 getting hit with a delay of this caliber
is a bummer all around, but better safe than
sorry.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
action franchises are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.